Today we go behind that power grab.
That was that wasn't.
Or what was it exactly, Will?
Right now,
we're going to try to answer
all of the questions that we have
about the revolt inside Russia.
The mercenary who led
what looked
and sounded like a revolt
is now
trying to answer one of those questions.
Why?
CNN just obtained
New audio of Prigozhin,
and he says the march to Moscow
was not a coup, but only a protest.
You know, somebody
saying you
two factors played into my decision
to turn around.
First factor,
we wanted to avoid a Russian bloodshed.
Second is
we marched in demonstration of a protest
not to overturn the power in the country
at this time.
Alexander Lukashenko extended his hand
and offered to find solutions
for the further work of Wagner, PMC
and legal jurisdiction.
CNN is covering this
story from all corners of the globe.
We're going to start our coverage
in London with CNN's Nic Robertson.
Nic, a pretty remarkable response
that we are hearing
for the first time
from the mercenary leader,
but it does also seem to comport
with the big ongoing argument
that Prigozhin had been having
with the defense minister, Sergei Shoigu.
What we learned from Prigozhin,
not just that he's saying
I wasn't trying to overthrow Putin
and we didn't mean or intend
to go out and kill any Russian troops.
They fired on us.
First walking by the helicopters.
He now says he shot down
But he says this was a march for justice.
His call that it was a march,
he said, to try to keep his Wagner
pm say his Wagner mercenary group alive.
He says in the audio
recording that it was going to be forced
to shut down on the 1st of July,
that he had talked
among the commanding officers
and with the men
and barely
any of them had agreed to
down tools for Wagner
and sign up for Russia's military
as was being demanded of them.
And he wanted to keep Wagner alive.
This is what he's saying.
And he goes on to say
when he was speaking to Lukashenko
and the reason
he accepted the Russian president's
offer to go and be an exile
there was because Lukashenko
offered him a way
for a legal jurisdiction for PMC Wagner
to keep
his private military contracting
company up and running.
This has been about power
and it's been about money.
Prigozhin has been
trying to fight off Russia's
defense minister
from taking control of Wagner,
his men
and the financial income potentially
that comes from it.
But I think one of the point
comes through
in this recording, and again,
we don't know when it was made.
But again, he takes a pot shot
at Sergei
Shoigu, the defense minister,
saying that this march was a protest
about the way the war was being run.
This is a very destructive message
for Putin
to continue to hear made publicly.
Oh, wow.
There is so much to unpack there.
Thank you so much.
For that critical, critical context.
Nick, I want to go now to Nick
Paton Walsh, who is in Kiev,
Ukraine's capital.
So, Nick, how will progressions comments
That this was a protest and not a coup?
And what he specifically said
that Nick was just reporting
about the way that the war inside
Russia is being prosecuted?
How will that land
where you are in Ukraine?
Yeah, I mean, it's sort of everything
relevant to some degree to Ukrainians,
so long as this remarkable
revenge tragedy
drama continues to play out.
Yevgeny Prigozhin showing
miscalculation, perhaps or not,
telling us the entirety of the story
that he somehow thought
he could take his troops, as he says,
hundreds of miles on the road
up to Moscow
and then suddenly change his mind
and not have Russian President
Vladimir Putin
think that that might have been
a challenge to the Kremlin, had himself
so keen to point out this notion of it
basically being a protest about
how Wagner was being treated
and the conduct of the war
rather than the challenge
to Moscow itself.
But this continues, as it seems.
Does progressions believe
that he can keep Virginia
as a group
alive, possibly inside of Belarus?
That's somewhat startling.
It may never indeed happen,
and we don't exactly know
where Prigozhin is
when he recorded this message.
He doesn't spell that out.
What does it mean
for Ukrainian officials?
Well,
it certainly means
that Vadim may continue to exist.
It certainly means that the question
of all this functionality
on the front lines hasn't been resolved,
and that could mean further tension
between the fighters
being asked to step down
and the regular Russian military
being asked
to try and ensure that occurs.
We've seen since
this began suggestions
that Ukraine is continuing to advance
possibly at the normal pace
of the past weeks in certain
key areas near
the symbolic city of Bachman.
We have fought so hard over the winter,
possibly in the south,
to where they're claiming
to take
another village as well,
and also
another advance unexpected in the far
west of the front lines
near the river near the city of Hesse on.
So things changing.
But I think really
the central message from
this is Prigozhin
perhaps stepping down,
not necessarily offering
we think
I think
a full explanation
as to his extraordinary
change of heart on the road,
definitely tallying
with the Kremlin's message
as of yesterday.
But it is still a startling,
I think,
vacuum of power to some degree
at the heart
of the Russian government here,
the defense minister
releasing prerecorded videos, Vladimir
Putin releasing prerecorded videos.
The live respondent has still
Yevgeny Prigozhin,
and that may be something
the Kremlin have to answer
in the days or hours ahead
just to reassure their own troops
that there's somebody
with their hand on the wheel.
Putin likes to basically set his own
agenda and appear when he feels like it.
But these are very
different circumstances.
And yet again,
we just seem to see a Russian elite here
miss communicating,
mis imagining
exactly what they can get away with.
Reverse that chart,
of course, exceptionally quickly.
Prigozhin Putin pardoning Prigozhin
startling series of affairs
and one that I'm sure Ukraine will hope
will yield disarray on the front lines
in the days or weeks ahead. Donna.
No question.
And we are just
really trying to read the tea
leaves on a lot of these statements
that we're getting in the last hour
from Prigozhin. From Prigozhin, rather.
Thank you so much for that.
I want to go back to the United States
and over to the Pentagon
where CNN's Natasha Bertrand is.
So Natasha Wagner's mercenary leader.
We were just talking about
he says this wasn't a coup attempt.
And specifically
what he said is that
this was a quote unquote protest.
And what he's protesting
is the idea that the Russian military
was trying to dissolve this Wagner
mercenary group and do so by July 1st.
Do your sources
there at the Pentagon, in the military
an American military,
believe that that's the case?
Well, Don,
this actually does comport with U.S.
officials understanding
broadly of what was motivating
Prigozhin in the days
leading up to this rebellion.
As you'll recall,
we did report over the weekend that U.S.
intelligence did see signs
that Prigozhin
was plotting
a potential major challenge to Russia's
military leadership.
And that was because
of the fact
that it appeared
that Russia's military
leadership was preparing
to usurp Faulkner
and try to absorb it
within the Russian military ranks.
And so what Prigozhin is saying here
essentially is that
he did not want to
overthrow the Russian government.
Now, it is unclear to US officials,
including in the run
up to this rebellion,
what his ultimate aim actually was,
if he wanted to only challenge
Russia's defense leaders
and perhaps spark change in that area,
or if he actually wanted
to try to overthrow Vladimir Putin.
As we saw over the weekend,
he did march towards Moscow.
And so that raised a lot of questions
in U.S.
official minds
about what he was actually doing.
U.S.
intelligence officials
were surprised, though,
that this wasn't a bloodier affair.
They believe that it is
that it is surprising
that Russia's troops
did not fight back harder.
And that is one of the main questions
that they're asking now is
why did
Russia did Wagner troops face
so little resistance from Russian troops?
But just in terms broadly
of what Prigozhin is saying here, U.S.
officials are monitoring
whether he is able
to reconstitute himself,
whether he is going to go
into exile in Belarus
and just how the Wagner forces
are actually going to be absorbed
within the Russian military
after months and months of Prigozhin
telling them
that the Russian Ministry of Defense
cannot be trusted
and has essentially
left them to die in Ukraine. Yeah.
Or if they will at all, considering
the fact
that it looks like
Prigozhin is suggesting
in this audio
recording that was just released
that he wants
to keep the Viognier group intact,
but just keep them inside Belarus.